hi everyone Thanks for
inviting me to participate in this uh in
this Workshop so I'll be talking today
about the higher dimensional expansion
of random geometric graphs slash
simplicial complexes but we're gonna
focus on kind of a graph picture because
I think it's easier to introduce the
definitions in that way and this is
based on joint work with sikilu sudanth
mohanti and Elizabeth young and I see at
least Saddam pansiki sitting in the in
the audience here so I've got a backup
in case we need to call it in
um
yeah this is not exactly a learning
theory topic Nora optimization topic yet
but perhaps
me
but uh but I'll try to make a case for
why it kind of is related a little bit
later just for atoms that he's not so
embarrassed okay so let's let's just get
started so uh we say that a graph
a Linda spectral expander
it's the second eigenvalue of G's
normalized adjacency Matrix which I'm
just going to denote like this
is upper bounded by Lambda which should
be strictly less than one and uh
expanders are one of the best things
that happen to
theoretical computer science I think
ever because you know once you have an
expander that satisfies this property
you get all kinds of uh consequences
which are really really nice like for
example a graph which is an expander has
no sparse cuts
so that's that's some kind of measure of
the connectivity of the of the graph and
also you get some other nice
consequences like uh random walks mix
fast
Etc and this makes them really useful in
in all kinds of applications like you
know like an error correcting codes or
designing failure tolerant networks and
stuff like this okay
so expanders are great and the first
time that you hear about an expander you
know you have this graph and it's really
well connected so maybe it's for
surprising that you can get expanders
which are which have constant sparsity
so there exists uh there exist expanders
with the number of vertices and going to
Infinity but uh average degree or
maximum degree
food
and constant
like uh and and it's not even that you
know this type of thing is rare because
it turns out to be the case that if you
sample a random graph then a random
sparse graph then if Will with high
probability be a expander so
here's a theorem
uh the different parts of it are due to
alone
and uh Friedman
it basically says the following
a random
irregular graph
meaning like a uniformly randomly
sampled irregular graph
has the best expansion possible
among all the irregular graphs
foreign
so you know what this means is that the
second eigenvalue is going to be like
this number which is called The Ramones
Unbound with high probability
so we learned that expanders are not
only awesome but they're also abundant
right and because random graphs have
this expansion property uh so for me at
least it gives me a way to to think
about what an expander is because I can
just think of this nice distribution
which I'm pretty good friends with
um
okay but so now you're maybe you're
happy maybe you're happy with with the
situation
um
but there's there's a now a higher
dimensional notion of expanders
uh which which I will introduce in a
second kind of this comes from the the
thinking okay so we know what uh
expansion means for graphs we're
satisfied with it but we want to now
think about what it means for hypographs
or simplicial complexes okay but but in
order to uh make the definition more
accessible I'm only going to be talking
about graphs so so for today if you're
if you're kind of like a hypergraph
simplicial complex expert this might
look a little funny to you but I'm just
doing this so that we can do the
definitions efficiently Okay so
in order to introduce what a higher
dimensional expander is I'm going to
introduce the following concept so if I
have a vertex
in a graph I say that the link
of the vertex
is just the graph induced on the
neighborhood of fotex
so let's just do an example
okay so in this graph what is the link
of the vertex a well it's supposed to be
the induced graph on the neighbors of a
so what I would do is I delete a and I
delete all of the vertices that aren't
touching a and then the link of a
just ends up being the four cycle of the
neighbors around it
okay this is the length of a
let's do just one more example let's
call this vertex V
okay when I delete B and all of the rest
of the vertices that don't touch me in
the graph I just get an independent sets
on three vertices so one could be
beautiful
like that
all right now I'll say a bit of graph G
is a two-dimensional expander
okay two-dimensional spectral Lambda
expander
if the following conditions are met
so first I'm going to require that g is
connected
that's true
fair enough
uh then I'm going to also require that
for every single one of the vertices
participating in G
the link
V
is a Lambda expander
so so every single one of these
neighborhoods when I uh when I take the
graph induced on them should be a land
expander and then thirdly I'm also going
to acquire the G itself
is an expander uh let's say that it's a
Lambda Prime expander
where Lambda Prime should be less than
one so I just want non-trivial expansion
for the whole graph
okay so these are the three conditions
that I want
so uh
right uh let's just give like one
example of a graph that's going to
satisfy this property so a really easy
example
is just the complete graph on N vertices
because what happens when you okay
complete graph on N vertices clearly an
expander clearly connected now think
about the neighborhood induced on any uh
Vertex or sorry the graph induced on any
protective's neighborhood you get
complete graph on N minus one vertices
also clearly an expander okay so so here
we have an example of a very very dense
two-dimensional expander
but after actually uh really
surprisingly maybe okay so surprisingly
there also exist
uh sparse so degree
order one
two-dimensional expanders
there are a couple of uh different
groups that I that you can credit with
the first construction of these so I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna write down
kind of the the pioneering constructions
but now there are there are a bunch more
okay and I'm in a whiteboard talk so I
don't have time to write them all down
but uh for example there's a lubotsky
uh Samuels conditioner
[Music]
it's actually slash Cartwright
Soleil
Juke maybe not sure how to pronounce
this and then there are more now
okay these these constructions kind of
come from the I think early 2000s
um
and yeah
I don't think for three but I think yeah
like a constant and think of the size
going to Infinity I mean it's just it's
like pretty incredible that these
objects uh
yeah I also kind of would have thought
it's not possible it's really it's like
it's weird that this is I agree that
this is a weird thing and again and the
thing about all these constructions is
that they're algebraic right so they're
based on uh taking some kind of uh Kali
graph and doing some stuff to it okay so
so for me uh that uh that means that I'm
not going I mean okay so for me I that's
kind of a less satisfying than a
situation where you have a nice
distribution over expanders because for
me it really helps me to think about the
object if I can think about a
distribution first for sampling from it
okay and then also this remember what I
said about about the about the case of
uh expanders themselves like the fact
that we know that a random graph has
this expansion property gives us some
kind of notion of the abundance of this
of this object whereas if you only have
a couple of algebraic instructions it's
not clear if this is kind of like a
natural thing or if it's kind of a freak
of Nature's situation yeah different our
standard expansion I care about it a lot
because of my missing a marketing yeah
okay okay so so that's a that's a great
question so I'm about to tell you
ethereum which is going to make you care
about this question so it's it's almost
as if I told you to ask that yeah these
constructions are explicit right these
are explicit instructions so is there
some way to show that like a random plus
small adjustment
s
yeah I'm going to talk about this so so
in one second I will address these
questions
okay so so here's like uh here's it so
so you should you might ask why uh why
are two energies interesting so here's a
theorem which I think really gets to to
the bottom of this and this is called
the trickling down theorem
and uh
I guess it's it's due to oppenheim but
similar ideas were previously I mean
much long ago um also used by Garland
foreign so what it states is that
if G is a Lambda two-dimensional
expander
with Lambda less than half
ten
automatically from the connection of G
and this Lambda expansion of all of the
links
uh you get you can drop you can drop
three you get it for free okay so the
the second eigenvalue of the graph the
graph itself is going to be an expander
with eigenvalue it's most Lambda over
one minus Lambda okay so notice that
this is a non-trivial bound this is less
than one exactly when Lambda is less
than half and okay here I'm cheating a
little bit because really I want this to
be some re-weighting of of G but but
let's not focus on that for now that's a
that's kind of like a subtlety okay so
so this is this is really amazing this
is amazing theorem it's the proof isn't
very difficult but the amazing thing is
that somehow expansion of the whole
graph which is a very Global property is
being witnessed locally like all I have
to do is I have to give you the pieces
of graphs of the neighborhood of every
single vertex I don't have to tell you
how they're fitting together but already
you can check if the whole graph is an
expander wait I'm missing something very
very basically yeah
no no no no uh sorry uh so okay this
isn't yeah good good I should I
shouldn't have said it like this
so let's say that if G only satisfies
conditions one and two so if it's one
connected
and two
for all of the vertices
the link
V has second eigenvalue
is a is a Lambda expander
foreign
less than half bounded away from half
then this is true okay so so it's like I
assume one and two and I get three for
free thank you for calling me out this
was really confusing what I said yeah
okay so this is this is a remarkable
thing about this two-dimensional
expansion it's the global expansion is
witnessed locally and this is really
useful in applications because you can I
mean you can witness Global expansion
locally so for example like expanders
are useful in error correcting codes but
with a higher dimensional expanders we
can get locally testable codes right
there are new constructions for locally
decibel codes so I mean okay or at least
without with objects that are kind of uh
with similar to high dimensional
expanders I mean maybe but this local to
Global phenomenon is really really uh
useful for this third
what do you mean
approved oh okay so I'll tell you
something that's like really uh I mean
it's not going to give you intuition for
the land like we'll have but think about
think about taking a random walk on the
whole graph okay somehow I can write it
as a combination of random walks on each
of the vertex neighborhoods right I can
I can kind of decompose it in this way
and when you do this decomposition and
and uh you're clever then you can get
this this result right so if you have
extreme enough expansion in each of the
local neighborhoods this gives you
expansion globally
okay so so great so then the the
starting point of of uh this work is is
the following question so are there
uh natural distributions
over
sparse
two-dimensional
expanders
it's like I know when I see it kind of
thing you know but uh okay like here's
something that it's not like a natural
distribution take you know take take
each one of these constructions and take
the uniform distribution over them okay
that's kind of like
so it is a distribution right so natural
okay so so okay so so I just wanna I
want a distribution that will help me
understand whether these two-dimensional
what these two-dimensional expansion
expanders are and whether they're like
abundant or rare okay so so it's a
qualitative thing but this is what I
want and let's just verify for a second
that the natural things that you might
do fail
okay so here's a here's an example
so let's just start off with the with
deregular graphs I mean why not they're
they're expanders Washington D2
dimensional standards so let's look at a
random D regular graph
foreign
okay so one thing about random deregular
graphs is that they're they're famously
locally tree-like
right so if I look at the neighborhood
of some vertex in a random deregular
graph
if we're in the situation where D is
much less than root n okay so average
degree listener can you guys see if I
write down here yeah you can at least
sit on the on the screen okay so so if
I'm in a situation where I do is much
less when you're done then the
neighborhood around a Vertex is going to
look uh like kind of like a tree right
but then what is the induced graph on
the the neighbors any vertex it's just
an independent sex like I said over here
right I cleverly set this up so that I
wouldn't have to redraw and read into
this example and then and then the point
is that in an independent set the second
eigenvalue is just one because I have a
bunch of disconnected components okay so
this is this is this is a bad example
and uh yeah we could go through a bunch
of other natural guesses that you might
have like air dish training graphs same
problem
all of these all of these kind of first
things that you would try seem to have
uh abound at a degree
Ruden so now like let's let's relax our
goal I mean ideally I'd like to have a
constant degree a distribution with
constant average degree over
two-dimensional expanders but but even
getting something with average degree
less than root n would be good
okay and indeed this is what we can do
so uh let me just say
first I'll say what we do
and then I'll tell you what the
distribution is and probably that will
take all the time that I have but I
really wanted to tell you guys about the
proof so
Let's cross our fingers
for that
okay so basically what we're able to
show is that for arbitrarily small
polynomial degree there is a nice
distribution over two-dimensional
expanders so for all Epsilon greater
than zero there exists a distribution
over uh into the Epsilon average degree
two-dimensional expanders
[Music]
uh which uh which furthermore have
Lambda
strictly bounded away from a half so
half minus Delta for Delta constant
okay so the expansion is good enough
that we trigger this trickling down
theorem and local expansion Witnesses
the global expansion that's the point
so so I'm just going to tell you what
this distribution is and then I'm going
to at least uh yeah I'll just tell you
what it is and then I'll State the
theorem more
concretely but the distribution is the
distribution of a random geometric
graphs on the sphere okay so uh I'm
gonna I'm gonna Define the following
distribution over graphs
it's the random geometric graph
distribution over the D dimensional
sphere with n vertices and Edge
probability P so how do I how do I do
this
the way I sample it is I first sample n
vectors uniformly at random
foreign sphere
okay so here's my
spear
indeed I mentioned
okay I'm going to sample
one vector
two vectors
Etc
these are going to be like the vertices
of my graph
okay and then in the Second Step I'm
going to add edge i j
to my Edge set
isn't only if
the inner product with UI and u j the
corresponding vectors exceed some
threshold Tau
okay so so what this means is basically
I I look around uh U1 and I kind of draw
a spherical path so that everything
inside the spherical cap has projection
at least Tau or larger onto un and then
I add it I add an edge between these
guys
okay and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to choose the threshold Tau so I
choose this
so that the marginal probability of any
Edge
is just P okay that's where this this
parameter P came from so this is
something that I chose I choose in
advance before sampling anything else
okay now the marginal probability of any
edges P so I get a random graph where
the average degree is n times p
and uh yeah and this is this is it
okay so the definition of this
distribution clear
not making these markers like they used
to
you're not getting constant degree we're
not getting constant degree
yeah I mean remember how I like moved
the goal post here a little bit so that
was a
not logarithmic yet I I'm also I'll I'll
tell you the I'll tell you the CRM right
now and then uh yeah so here here's our
kind of main theorem
so for any
constant Epsilon
uh
there exists some other consonant
also depending on Epsilon especially if
you choose d
to the C Epsilon Times login
then
a graph sampled from
the random geometric distribution in D
Dimensions with uh and vertices and Edge
probability
foreign
Over N to the one minus Epsilon so
meaning average degree NC Epsilon
then G is a two dimensional expander
with Lambda equal to half minus Delta
with high probability
and Delta is exponentially small
in one over Epsilon okay so if Epsilon
is a constant then this is bounded away
from half by constant and if Epsilon is
uh subconstant then it's not but still
you know we have some kind of a
guarantee on that on eigenvalues okay
and also G is connected I guess that
connected
what Lambda contain in terms of do you
not off the top of my head I mean I mean
these I mean not these constructions but
some of the following constructions can
get Lambda to be arbitrarily close to
zero Okay so I mean like you know for
General things we know oh yeah yeah like
you mean like some kind of like alone
style uh band not that's my knowledge uh
nuggets like quality but I I don't know
what though but it's like square root or
something else yeah like with the Romano
John special food would be I guess
probably couldn't get something that
would and you get one of them
probably you can if you back solve to
figure out what Lambda can be in order
to get uh the Ramon is Unbound for the
whole graph and I would guess that
that's that's some kind of gone but I
don't know if anything's sharp I don't
know if it's known what's the sharp yeah
so actually those uh constructions uh
the other red ones do Half-Life the
second argument the overall graph like
whatever it would be but uh I don't
think that's witnessed by the title out
here electrical language
yes
okay so uh so right so so there's our
theorem and I feel my feeling is that
this is a fairly natural distribution
okay again I said I know when I see it
in here I'm not objective at all but I
think this is a pretty natural
distribution over graphs that are at
least sparse sparse-ish two-dimensional
expanders okay so so this is a this is
the the main result
um how much time do I have left five
minutes okay in these five minutes maybe
I'll just give like a tiny taste of what
the proof would look like
um because this is where also the
application to learning uh will will
show up but okay but so first of all
like why might you expect that a random
geometric graph would give you a
two-dimensional expansion so I'll say
something really really hand wavy which
isn't very precise but maybe I can
follow up later and and strengthen this
a little bit so
okay so what you want kind of is that
within the neighborhood of every vertex
you're more likely to have connections
than the ambient uh Edge probability
but in a geometry right this is kind of
exactly what we have like if I have some
vertex I and it's adjacent to both J and
K and somehow these edges are coming
from some kind of underlying geometry
then J and Care are also a little bit
more likely to be close by right so so
this is one intuition why this might be
a good place to turn to to look for for
this kind of thing
so uh
triangle inequality I'm just gonna write
here
so you have to show a random graph with
gap is
exactly exactly okay now now let's talk
about the sphere this is this leads in
just so it leads in so perfectly to what
I was going to say so okay so so now
we're in a sphere right
we have we have a random uh
we're doing a random geometric graph on
a sphere and let's think of first of the
random geometric graph as being like a
some kind of discrete approximation to
the sphere itself
foreign
okay so G itself is going to be kind of
like
this is some kind of a
approximation to the sphere right G is a
discrete
rocks to
Spirit but then what is the link of the
vertex V well remember that we said that
we were just going to
if this is if this is some vertex V
its corresponding vector
its neighbors are just going to be all
the other vectors that fell into the
spherical cap around V okay so this is
some spherical cap of measure P
and so the links in this graph if we if
we use this kind of same uh idea that
you know we basically are getting some
kind of discrete approximation to the
the geometric objects itself the link
the V is going to be approximately like
the spherical path
of measure P
now the cool thing about the sphere is
that
if I'm in high Dimensions right like
remember that I'm taking my Dimension
growing to Infinity within then almost
all of the mass or the probability mass
and the uniform distribution over this
cap is here at the boundary
but if if I just take the boundary
itself
what is this this is a sphere in one
lower dimension right because I'm fixing
the value in this coordinate right and
now I'm just looking at a lower
dimensional sphere and so somehow the
whole game
is if you can show that uh the I get I
mean if you can if you can show that the
sphere is an expander then automatically
you should also get that the cap is an
expander what we do is it's not quite
automatic but it's it's like close
enough to automatic okay so so our first
step
is to kind of prove like a meta theorem
about the eigenvalues of random
restrictions of graphs right like the
sphere is kind of like an infinite graph
this cap is also kind of an infinite
graph and when I take a random geometric
graph I'm sort of taking a random
restriction right I'm just sub sampling
it
okay
okay so in the proof
step one is to prove a
much
that ethereum
about random restrictions about the
Spectrum
and uh and actually this meta theorem I
think could have applications in in
other situations like for example one
thing that it automatically gave us is
it gave us an understanding of the
spectrum of the sphere itself okay which
gives a bound on the eigenvalues of
random geometric graphs which
is the first uh like kind of type
characterization of the spectrum of
random geometric graphs and this this I
think should have a lot of applications
in data science right because you know
we can model distributions over graphs
as random geometric graphs in in some
cases and there it's like very useful to
understand the Spectrum for applications
and algorithms so I can I can talk more
about that maybe after uh if you're
interested
okay and then step two
is really to kind of understand
the Spectrum
of the spirit
so in step one really what I mean is
it's a statement of the form like you
know if random walks mix really fast on
the original graph then the eigenvalue
is in the random restriction are are
good so then we need to understand what
is the Spectrum in the in the original
graph okay and then this still doesn't
say anything about the
uh about the
you know about why we need to take the
average degree to be constant but but
this is this is maybe some some
calculation that I was like in my
wildest dreams going to do but I guess
I'm not going to end up being able to do
so so effectively uh this is this is
kind of what what's going on
um maybe I can just conclude with a with
one open question I mean I guess it's
maybe it's kind of obvious but okay but
what you might ask is here's a question
foreign
so we know that for this distribution uh
our bounds are sort of tight so you
shouldn't be able to get as far as like
a poly logarithmic average degree or
constant average degree construction
based on the sphere okay but maybe
there's some other geometry where you
can do this so
is there a different
geometry
oh where a random geometric graph
William
constantly sparse
so something that we know is that you
can't just take an arbitrary geometry
and have this be the case and I'll give
you one maybe I'll just give you one
example to make it concrete okay so so
remember that the whole point is that we
want that local expansion Witnesses
Global expansion but I'm going to show
you two different geometries one of them
is a globally expanding geometry and the
other one's uh only locally expanding
geometry or sorry one of those global
expanding geometry and the other one is
a not globally expanding geometry and
the local neighborhoods are going to
look the same
so the example I want you to have in
mind is uh on the first in the first
case we have the expanding just a a
graphical metric with a regular expander
so here I've got like a deregular
expander
so so a deregular expander it can also
be a metric space where every vertex is
a point in the metric space and
distances are defined by the graph
distance
and you could have a random geometric
graph in this space with some kind of
just whatever distance threshold you
want
and on the other hand I can have two uh
deregular expanders on N over two
vertices which are connected by a bridge
so this is a d regular expander
and this is the regular expander
but there's a really sparse cut here but
the point is that the local
neighborhoods look the same okay so so
this is just to say that like a generic
geometry isn't going to work out for you
you need a special property of the
geometry and the kind of cool thing
about this sphere is that just by seeing
a single link here you can tell what
dimension of sphere you're in you can
kind of like the curvature tells you
what kind of sphere you need to be in
and so this this uh tells you that you
have an I mean this this says that this
is an okay geometry to look at
um but I don't know which geometry will
be better than the sphere and I'm if you
have any thoughts I'm really excited to
hear that go ahead yeah thanks
[Applause]
thank you
oh well maybe like since lunch is now
like maybe if you want to for people who
are interested you want to like casually
it's great but I mean maybe if you want
to casually show the calculations
[Applause]
foreign